following the devastation of Hurricane
Katrina in 2005 our next guest authored
an extensive report on the federal
government's response Fran Townsend was
president george w bush's homeland
security adviser and is now CBS news
senior national security analyst fran
good morning good morning anything what
what principally did you learn from
looking at that you know look what you
understand is the federal government is
not equipped to be the first responder
it's never going to be right the first
responder is the person in your local
community the problem in a devastating
natural disaster is those people are
also victims and so they're not really
in a position they may be the most
competent first responders that you've
got but they're not in a position
they've got their families and their
homes to worry about you're sitting
there's no bus drivers there's no police
because they're all home trying taking
care of their family exactly right and
so what we found in Katrina was the
quicker you surge forces that can
actually act and and put in place
expeditionary logistics the quicker
you're gonna see your recovery what does
that mean the people who are the best in
the world at this or the US military
right now there are 7,200 troops there
they need thousands more they're gonna
you know they've got the Army Corps of
Engineers that's right that will help in
terms of getting electricity both
transmission and distribution but
they're they need a lot more help right
now until they can get on their feet
frame we we heard praise for the
administration after Harvey and ermine
the way they handled things but now
we're hearing two very different stories
from Puerto Rico and then from the
administration why is there this
disconnect what changed sure first of
all you know you'll learn kind of the
hard way and Tom Bossard who's in my old
position the homeland security adviser
helped me author the lessons learned
report so he gets this oftentimes the
information you're getting from the site
of a natural disaster the first reports
are wrong a and B the people on the
ground have the best information so the
mayor and the governor know the best
what their own constituents are dealing
with and you have to defer to them you
have to listen to them and respond to
their needs the best example of this is
the Jones Act right to the short the
short explanation of that is
foreign-flag ships typically are not
permitted in to deliver these products
on
US carriers can't do it and the
administration's view was they got all
the commodities into Puerto Rico they
didn't need that to waive the Jones Act
governor calls and says law do you do
and they did it right away and that's a
good example of you've got to listen to
the people on the ground you mentioned
getting getting goods in and that we've
seen there there been there been you
know lots of stuff stacked up at ports
but not able to get it out anywhere so
we're we're if there was the failure
there do you think in terms of we know
that there's a shortage of drivers but I
mean could that not have been
anticipated well you know it's the right
question and Anthony and I don't think
we have a good answer yet
I do think you've got a they had a
three-star general at Northern Command
here in the United States who was
overseeing the response and a one-star
general on the ground sort of executing
against the plan I think what they've
seen now the three-star general is on
his way if he's not already arrived in
Puerto Rico to evaluate the response and
what the requirements are I'd be
surprised if he didn't say I need more
troops in order to to manage this
distribution until quert Oh Rico itself
can get back on its feet why did it take
so long to get that three-star general
in place what you mentioned before was
the idea that the army knows how to deal
with this and they should be the ones
well to be fair my understanding from
the White House is that that three-star
general has been in place literally from
the beginning but he was managing sort
of his role from the from the mainland
us and I think that the the sort of
adjustment has been there gonna send him
down there to understand better on the
ground what the requirement as you were
saying you need to be there all right
Fran Townsend thank you some great
perspective